Alright guys, so let's make these emoji and Minion eggs,...
You will need some plastic eggs...
...either spray paint or craft paint would do, a paint brush, some eyeballs...
...and some Sharpie markers.
Alright, so the first step is to paint the eggs...
...and you can use spray paint or craft paint, whatever you like.
Start with a primer and then paint on your main coat.
For my little Minion guy, I'm painting on the pants with some blue craft paint.
Then, let it set dry on a little cap.
On the top part of your egg, draw a black line around.
Now for the mouth, eyebrows, then glue on one or two eyeballs.
For the emoji part, I just look at the picture for guidance...
...and I use my Sharpie markers to draw in the face.
After that I would use a red, white and blue paint to add in the details.